an asylum seeker who was told he would
be going on this flight to rwanda has
given us his account of what happened
we've been following the progress of an
iraqi man zahir not his real name who's
spoken to us by phone from kolnbrook
detention center near heathrow talk me
through
what happened yesterday they say that
you have
come to take to the plate
i see my face
i see that the court hasn't finished it
yet they say you have to take you and i
i don't have so
they take me by four they
it was the four of them two of them take
my hand um
take my
feet and one of them
so what happened after that so then were
you put in a van
push me
out of seven men taken to the airport
five boarded the plane tuesday night but
at the last minute all had their
deportation at the very least postponed
after the european court of human rights
ruled in one man's appeal that the
government needed to wait for next
month's judicial review which will rule
on whether the rwanda policy itself is
legal the courts in london decided that
it was fine for them to be sent to
rwanda on the basis they would be there
for only a few weeks before the high
court reaches a decision by the end of
next month the strasbourg court the
human rights court decided that they
couldn't be sure they would be brought
back and therefore took a different view
sophie lucas whose firm represents three
of the men says this shouldn't be
portrayed as the eu overruling the uk
the european convention on human rights
was part drafted and signed by winston
churchill and is incorporated into our
uk domestic laws
the question here is not we broke the
rules how can we get rid of them it's we
broke the rules how can we make policies
that comply with them the home secretary
says the policy is legal and humane
it has saddened me madam deputy speaker
to see rwanda so terribly misrepresented
introduced in his century
it is another example of how all too
often critics not only don't know what
they're speaking about but seek to
vilify another international country
that has a good track record when it
comes to refugees and stepping up to
international responsibilities shadow
home secretary yvette cooper the
opposition says the policy was always
set to fail this is not and never has
been a serious policy and she knew that
when she chartered the plane
she knew that among the people she was
planning to send to rwanda on this plane
were torture and trafficking victims the
government insists they need to stop the
cruel trafficking of asylum seekers
across the channel and more than a
hundred more arrive today
but zahir who's made this crossing says
actually the government is behaving just
like the traffickers i told them i told
them
that you and the trafficker
yeah
told us to
do something and we say not and
so you were reminded of what it was like
being trafficked
yeah it was the same thing it was not
different this is that uk
democratic country they say where is the
human right i don't know
just tell you the difference between
them and the traffickers
the security firm involved mighty told
sky news our focus is on treating the
people in our care with dignity and
respect and we are confident that our
officers have acted professionally the
firm said staff wore body cameras and
restraint is only ever used as a last
resort to ensure the safety of those
traveling and their staff members jason
farrell sky news